[MUSIC PLAYING]
SHAHID HUSSAIN: Hi, everyone.
My name's Shahid.
I'm a product manager
on the Chrome OS team.
And welcome to all
of you to our session
on developing Android
apps on Chrome OS.
Now, we talked about
this last year at I/O.
And if you saw that talk,
today's talk is a continuation.
We're going to be
talking about the basics
briefly, and talking
about how we've
worked with a number of
you over the past year,
and as well sharing a
number of new features
that we'd love to
tell you about.
So first of all, let's talk
about why this matters.
So we've talked previously
about the success of Chromebooks
within the education
space, where we outsell
every other device combined.
But Google's really been
doubling down on Chrome OS.
You've hopefully been inundated
by ads over Q4 last year
and ongoing this year.
And that's helped drive
demand in the consumer space,
too, so much so that in Q4
last year, 17% of notebooks
sold in the US were Chromebooks.
[APPLAUSE]
So why does this matter to
you, Android developers?
So the headline here is,
Android apps work on Chrome OS.
How does that happen?
It works via the
Android framework
running inside a
container that sits on top
of the base of Chrome OS.
And the full Play Store
is already available.
So your app is probably
already running on Chrome OS.
Now, ultimately, what we
care about is a good user
experience.
Part of that is the
operating system itself.
And part of that is the apps
that users choose to run.
And we've been investing heavily
in improving the product.
And those of you who use
Chrome OS over the past year
have seen evidence of that in
system updates you've gotten.
And many of you who
are developing apps,
we've already been working
with to ensure that you're--
ensuring that the apps work
really well on Chrome OS.
Adobe, Roblox, Sony,
EA, and many, many more
have already included Chromebook
optimizations in their latest
updates onto the Play Store.
And that's opening up
different kinds of usage
and different kinds of revenue.
May Allen, PM from
Evernote, told us,
"Pixelbook users are
spending four times more time
in Evernote than an
average app user."
And Andrew and David, founders
from Steadfast Innovation, who
make the Squid app,
told us that Chromebooks
have made up 21% of their
revenue over the last 30 days.
So first of all, to
begin, we're quickly
going to review some basics.
Ensuring that an app
works well on Chrome OS
comes down to four key
differences between Chromebooks
and phones--
wider screens, default
landscape, window management,
and different primary
input devices--
keyboard, pointer, stylus.
First, wider screens--
Chromebook screens are bigger--
from 10.1 inch on the smaller
side to 15 inch on some
of our larger units.
So apps need to be able to work
well at all of these widths
and respond appropriately
to resize events.
For example, AID's
coding lessons
now switch to a
two-column view when
the app is resized to be wider.
Second, default landscape-- as
a default landscape device, apps
need to have a really
great landscape experience.
And so for example, PocketCasts
pins open its navigation menu
and arranges items
in a grid so they
can fill the space available,
rather than lifting items out
with whitespace to the right.
Third, multi-window-- Chrome
OS is a multi-window desktop
environment.
The SignEasy and Sony Sketch
apps in their latest versions
on the Play Store
are now resizable,
so users can work better with
these inside our environment.
And finally, maybe the
most important, keyboard
and mouse inputs--
when a user pulls out
a laptop and uses it,
the keyboard and touchpad
are closer to the user.
So they gravitate towards
them as their primary inputs.
So the Infinite Painter
team is an example--
built keyboard accelerators
for common commands
so users can get around
faster inside the interface.
And that's especially
true for games.
So Pixonic-- they
make War Robots--
built keyboard controls
into their game.
The game now uses a
special manifest flag
to get inputs directly
from Chrome OS
and enable standard
WASD gaming controls.
So these are just
a few of the app
teams who are now
building and testing
their apps for Chrome OS.
And a huge, huge thank
you to everyone--
many of you are here
in the audience--
that we've worked with.
We're always looking
for apps that
work really, really
great on Chrome OS
so that we can show them off.
And we want your app
to be one of them.
Now, to talk about some of the
latest improvements in Chrome
OS for Android app
developers, I'd
like to hand over to Stefan,
one of our lead engineers
on Chrome OS.
Please welcome Stefan.
[APPLAUSE]
STEFAN KUHNE: Morning, everyone.
I'm glad that you could
all join for today's talk.
And I'm here to talk
about, well, all our latest
news, what we have done,
and what you can do in order
to improve your application even
more for a desktop environment.
So first slide, what is new?
So that is one of
the things which
is most important for
the user, but of course,
also has some impact
on what you are doing.
And then advanced
things you can do.
We have added a lot of
stuff over the last year.
And we really
wanted to show that.
And we hope that you are
actually making best use of it.
And last of it--
best practices.
So when you are following
these best practices,
you will have a better
chance in the Play Store,
because you will develop.
And we make sure of that.
So what's new?
Let's see.
So first off, we have
improved our tablet mode.
Why did we do that?
Because we have now, also,
a tablet-only device.
Well, and what did we change?
Well, there are
smoother animations.
We have removed the caption bar.
So it means the
window control bar.
And the controls on
the nav bar, they
are actually now moving
down into the shelf,
as you can see there.
And also, all windows
are automatically
started full screen, which is,
of course, the experience what
you expect on a tablet.
So next thing is split screen.
We have added split
screen, which is--
well, you know that,
of course, from phones.
But now, on a big tablet
and/or bigger screen,
it makes, of course,
much more sense.
So you can split, now, the
screen with any kind of window
which is available on Chrome OS.
So it might be--
well, might be a Chrome
window, might be, of course,
an Android window.
The only thing
is, at the moment,
you will not be able to figure
out that you are actually
running in split screen.
We will add that later.
The next thing is we have
added picture in picture.
So it's a full specification
according to Android O.
And it is coming soon.
And you can resize a window.
You can actually place
it at multiple locations.
And it will be fairly similar
to the one which we are using
for web applications, as well.
So we have also added
the Android keyboard.
So you can essentially
replace, now,
coming soon, the Chrome OS
keyboard with an Android
keyboard, which makes
a lot of people happy.
Notifications-- we have
overhauled our notifications.
They are looking,
now, much more alike.
So color scheming and everything
should be much more integrated.
You have to tap, now,
instead of swiping.
And everything is much more
integrated into the Chrome OS
style in itself.
Pro audio-- so we have
actually added, since M65,
beginning of this year,
M, that's our milestones.
I don't know if you know that.
But it's essentially,
like, every six weeks,
we have a new release cycle.
And M65 is out
already since a while.
And MIDI is in since a
while in our Pixelbook.
And soon, we will also have
multichannel audio, USB audio--
multichannel USB, AAudio,
AAudio Memory Mapped.
And this is all coming
later this year.
And with that, you
have actually seen,
when you were coming in,
someone playing music here.
He was actually
using a Pixelbook.
And to show you a little
bit more about that,
I want to invite
Federico Tessmann
from-- the founder of
Algoriddim to actually show
how this works.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thank you.
So you have possibly seen
how everything was really
real time, synchronized
with the device,
and everything is real time.
So it's getting
more interesting.
Advanced things, now, what
you can do to your application
in order to make
your life-- well,
to make the life on
a desktop better.
Well, become desktop native--
I think I had that
already last year.
But we have, of course,
a follow-up on that one.
So first off, this
is something which
is something everybody knows
from everyday business, right?
Menu accelerators.
They are not really
something special, right?
But the thing is,
if you were using
the toolkit UI in the past,
it was actually from A.
I think it was like, I
don't know, Angel Cake,
or whatever Android
was back then.
So it means, like,
really ancient.
So the display was small.
And they had to actually
fit everything on there.
And it looked ugly.
It was really not
meant to be prime time.
So we have actually
changed the library
to make this much, much
easier for you to actually
get these kind of things in.
And all you have
to do is you have
to go into your layout
XML you use in your menu.
You put into the item itself,
then there's a shortcut,
means the character
and the modifier keys.
And you're ready to go.
Well, not entirely, but if
you're using a standard menu,
you have to actually call
then the set QWERTY--
what was it again?
Set QWERTY mode to true so
that you are actually getting
alphanumeric characters.
OK, this is really old,
but it's still there.
So shelf integration--
that is something, like,
if you want to do
something inside the shelf,
you want to change your
icon-- like, for example,
you're opening a
document or whatnot,
you want to change the
shape of the icon itself,
or you want to display then the
document which you have opened,
you can actually do that with
this setTaskDescription--
very simple and very effective.
Next thing is, if
you want to combine
multiple items inside the
shelf into one menu item,
you can actually put
then myIntent.putExtra.
You put then the
shelf shortcut to it.
And you take then
any kind of string
for a kind of modifier,
which you actually know.
And you actually then reuse
it for all the items you
want to put into the same set.
App shortcuts are coming.
So this is something
which is coming soon.
It's there already
since, I think, NMR1.
And we will support
them very soon, as well.
So essentially, you
can actually have
actions and any
kind of short things
which you want to do in
order to get the user
fast access to things.
The Back button-- well,
I think many of you,
since you were already doing
something for Chrome OS,
have already seen that
there's a back button
up in the window control bar.
Well, you have
also a back button.
We know that.
And the problem
was, of course, two
on top of each other
looks pretty crappy.
So therefore, by adding
this special meta flag,
you can get rid of it.
Makes it much, much
nicer, and that helps.
But there's one other
thing, and this is, I think,
even more important.
If you are on a desktop,
and you are pressing
backspace, or escape, or
navigate back, or whatnot,
and your window
suddenly disappears,
it's something which is
very unexpected as a user.
Please don't do that.
So if you can do it,
please, what you should do
is you should actually
check if your activity is
at the bottom of-- well,
at the root of the stack.
And if it is, and you know
that you are windowed,
please don't close your window.
Please keep it open,
because it's really,
really unexpected and
disturbing for the user
if suddenly all his
work is suddenly gone.
Lifetime management-- so we
were getting a lot of requests
from users which said,
well, you know what?
My application isn't really
running multitasking.
Well, why is it
not multitasking?
Well, because the
thing is, like,
I have this game I'm playing.
And I'm also checking
my news status.
And the news status isn't
updating while I'm playing.
But I would really
like to see that.
Well, there are
actually three states.
There's running, there's
paused, and there's stopped.
Running and paused means you
are visible on the screen, which
means not that you
should actually
drop everything and stop that
when you're getting a pause.
No, you can actually continue
to run, unless you are high,
whatever game, where you have to
have a lot of real-time action
and whatnot, where you
maybe want to really pause.
In most cases, you really
want to continue running.
So please do this, and you
make a lot of users much,
much happier.
Next thing, sharing data--
well, I said already
earlier that we
have plenty of windows
on our desktop, right?
So there are all kinds of Chrome
OS, your window, and whatnot.
If you don't specify
DRAG_FLAG_GLOBAL,
and you are doing a
drag-and-drop operation,
it will not be dropped
on another application.
This is then only for you.
So in order to allow
other applications
to actually get your data,
pre-specify this flag.
And if you are actually getting
some data from someone, well,
also check out what
you are getting.
If you are simply
blindly taking text,
well, you might
actually miss out
of all the richness of the
data which comes with it.
So therefore, please
check that out, as well.
And if you're looking
at the clipboard,
it's exactly the same thing.
You definitely want
to have, of course,
all the richness of whatever
is being copied and pasted,
as well.
So with that, resizing--
I was talking last
year about resizing,
that it's a really
big problem, right?
Because resizing looks pretty
clunky on Android in general
when you are doing this.
So here is a solution for you.
This is an application which
was written for Material Design
2.0.
And it looks nice on a phone.
See, this looks,
actually, pretty nice.
So when you are doing--
when you're following the design
study from Material Design,
they were coming with this
thing for tablet form factor.
See, there's more information.
You can actually
see more things.
And they are
revealing more stuff.
So with that, let me show you
a short demo of my notebook.
So there's the application.
And you can resize it.
And as you can see,
while I'm resizing it,
more and more data is
actually coming into play.
And see, more stuff
is coming-- whoops.
That was, of course,
the wrong guy.
Eh, there you go.
And you see that more and
more data is coming in.
This is all
dynamically happening.
And it's very fluid,
without a restart, which
is usually the problem, right?
Can I go back to
my slides, please?
So first off, good news--
the demo is actually online.
You can download it.
You can test it all yourself.
It's on GitHub.
And there's also an
excellent Codelab, which
is actually even showing more.
So you can also be
doing animations
while you're transforming
from one layout
into another, which is
then looking really cool.
You should check out
the Codelab for sure.
So how is it being done?
Well, first off, you need to
have a constrained layout state
file.
It's like a blueprint,
which is essentially
getting all the
different layouts
into some kind of order,
when to use which one.
And then comes the tricky part.
Every of these
layouts need to have
all UI elements which you use.
So if you don't want to see--
if you want to show it, then
you simply hide the thing.
If it's hidden, it doesn't show.
But it's still in
the layout itself.
And by doing this, and in
onCreate, you will actually
create then the
transition which you
want to use when you want to
transition from one to another.
And you set the
onConstraintsChanged layout
handler.
You will be able to do--
to add then the
pre-layout change handler,
which is then essentially like
giving the control to the--
sorry-- which is giving the
control to our layouter.
And we're just doing there
the transition itself.
So inside your activity,
what you have to do
is you have to add the
onConfigurationChanged handler,
which is usually being called
every time when something
changes, like the virtual
keyboard is disconnected,
the screen resolution changes,
or anything like that.
And from there,
you are essentially
calling the constrained
change layout handler
to actually let them
know what the size is.
And that will actually then
do all the work for you.
And finally, you will actually
add inside the Android manifest
file the request that you want
to handle all configuration
changes for size changes.
And with that, you are done.
If you want to
try it out, again,
try the Codelab to
actually get this done.
So the next thing
is zero-latency ink.
What does zero-latency ink mean?
Well, you have possibly
had already a pen.
You were trying
to draw something.
And you see, there is a lag
between drawing something,
or using the pen, and seeing
something on the device itself.
So where is it coming from?
Well, first off, you
have to read the sensor.
You have to do the
input processing.
You have to then do
the app code, whatever
the application is doing.
You have to do some
drawing with OpenGL.
Then, you're actually
doing multiple buffering,
because you have to
actually pass everything
through the compositor, which
is then compositing everything
on the Chrome OS side, or
whatever operating system
you have, the compositing side.
And just going through
the entire pipeline,
which might be for
images, or whatnot.
So in total, you're coming out
to 100 milliseconds of delay,
which is very, very noticeable.
So the ideal thing is,
of course, you simply
remove all the compositing.
So now we are down to,
well, roughly two frames,
which is less than 32
milliseconds, right?
But if we are adding, now, also,
the prediction logic to it,
well, then, we are really
at pretty much zero--
so mission accomplished.
And with that, I will actually
hand it over to Paolo Rivera,
a comic book author,
which is showing us
the whole thing in action.
[APPLAUSE]
PAOLO RIVERA: Hi.
Thank you.
Hi, everyone.
Hm, let's see.
Whoops.
All right, can you guys
see what I got up there?
So I drew some Spider-Man.
That's typically what
I'm known for at Marvel.
But I also drew Thanos.
Did anyone see
"Infinity War" yet?
[CHEERING]
All right, I did too.
All right, so what I like about
this app is you can rotate.
You can draw at any angle.
You can also do layers.
This is Infinite
Painter, by the way.
So what I've done is I've
drawn Spidey ahead of time.
And I'm going to
ink on top of him
using some of the inking tools.
Oh, I got to change my color.
I'm from the school of
thought where Spider-Man
should have expressive eyes.
And so I'm glad that they
did that in the movies.
Some people don't like
doing the webbing, but I do.
It does add a little bit
of time to each panel,
but it's worth it in the end.
And then, of course, you
can add color, as well.
I put in a layer
already with a red base.
And I might add
some shadow to it.
One of the other features
I like about this is you
can double tap to reset it.
And then, if you hold and
long press, it'll flip it.
So as a comic book
artist, I'm always
flipping things, if I
can, because it gives you
a fresh perspective.
And of course, there's
all kinds of drawing tools
that you can use.
Some are more
painterly than others.
And what I did was I clipped
the shadow layer to the layer
beneath it, which means that
everything I do on this layer
will be bounded by
the layer below it--
one way to save time.
And of course, the other
nice thing about the stylus
is it has tilt. So in
this case, I made tilt--
depending on which
way I hold the pen,
it will give me a
thick or thin line.
I could do this all day.
[LAUGHTER]
I usually do.
Usually, there aren't
this many people
watching while I'm drawing.
Y'all are lucky I'm
even wearing pants.
[LAUGHTER]
And let's finish it off
with some Spidey sense,
because Thanos is nearby.
And he's a Malthusian.
There we go.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
STEFAN KUHNE: Thanks.
OK, so how was it done?
So we have an ink
overlay view, which
is a new thing, which is
not yet really public.
If you want to get access
to it, there's a QR code.
Please grab it and sign
up for our release.
So it will actually be added
then to our release notes
as soon as we are
giving you access to it.
But essentially, we have--
well, you can see the code.
And it might change
a little bit.
So multi-display, which
is another topic--
so it's a very big
topic, because the thing
is, like, on a phone, you
have two screens, right?
You have the internal screen.
You have an external
screen, maybe.
If you're really creative,
and you have a Pixelbook Pro,
you might actually get
up to seven screens.
I'm not entirely sure.
I've heard that it's possible.
But the thing is, what
does it mean for you?
Well, actually, it means a lot.
Because the thing
is many applications
are doing stupid things.
Sorry, you are not that, right?
But the thing is, for
example, simply using, hey,
I want to get the display
information for display ID 0,
which is the default
display, right?
Well, seeing as it's not the
default display, because what
is the default display?
You don't know that, right?
So therefore, we have,
actually-- if you are pre-O,
then we are thinking that you
are a non-multi-display-aware
application.
And in this case, we have
a special thing for you
to make your life easier.
And essentially, 0 is
like a virtual display,
which is always the
display you are on.
And therefore, the
anti-API is really clear.
Everything is exactly
as it should be.
But the thing is you get
this kind of special display
so that you're working fine.
If, however, on the other hand,
you are actually something
after O, or O, then
you will actually
get a different treatment.
In that case, you will get the
real IDs, the real display IDs.
So therefore, if you are
doing these kind of things,
you should be careful
what you are doing.
And yeah, one additional
thing is if you are actually
running an [? NYC ?]
application,
you still have the
setLaunchDisplayId
as a function call.
So what should you do?
Well, you should definitely
use the size of the window.
So always use your context and
try to get the display metrics
from that.
That is working
perfectly for you.
And if you want to see any
kind of changes-- like,
for example, you have moved
to a different display,
or something like then look
at onConfigurationChange
to see these kind of changes.
And if you want to
actually position yourself,
think also about setting
the setLaunchDisplayId
if you do not want to
get to the same screen
where your current
application is on.
What you shouldn't do
is you shouldn't really
assume anything--
well, without
using your context.
If you are using any
kind of display ID,
trying to get the
default display,
you will get something which
is most certainly wrong.
And also, what was that?
Yeah, don't make any assumptions
that you are actually
on the [INAUDIBLE] display,
because that is definitely
wrong, as well.
And last but not least, don't
assume that you're always
running on the same display.
So presentation API--
we were being asked
to actually get this to you.
We are getting that
very, very soon.
And it is-- actually, I
think, pretty much by now, it
should be there.
You can alternatively also
use setLaunchDisplayId
and setLaunchBounds,
which will actually
do pretty much the same thing.
3D and gaming--
so what is there?
So basically, we have Vulkan
support for, for example,
the Pixelbook.
It was actually
shipping already.
1.0 was already shipping
beginning of this year.
1.1 should be
shipping around now.
And older architectures
are also on the way.
So Vulkan is much
faster and so on.
So when you are
building your own game,
one-- so there are a few
things that you should actually
take care of.
First off, you should always
use the latest version
of the framework.
If you're using
Unity and whatnot,
they are actually
fixing their stuff.
So if, for example, a window
size changes and whatnot,
and they have the
input region, which
is changing it a
little bit, they
will actually fix that for you.
So please use the latest
one, because otherwise,
your application will fail when
you are trying to be resized.
So the next thing is, also, use
either 64-bit or 32-bit native
code as well.
Don't use only ARM,
because ARM is, of course,
a little bit slower, especially
on the high-end devices.
So when you are running a game,
application quality control
might actually be bad
for you, depending
on what you are doing.
So if you have, for example,
multiple surfaces and whatnot,
and you are trying then to
squeeze out the latest thing,
and if you are running into
a state where you're using,
suddenly, quadruple
buffering, because you
are being composited on
the desktop or something,
your quality control might
actually do something negative
to your quality.
And you get some kind of
really weird behaviors.
So therefore, try it out on
Chromebooks before you release
it.
That would be really awesome.
And yeah, if you're
using a lot of layers,
like a lot of surface
use and whatnot,
you might also fall out of this.
And then your quality
might actually drop.
So therefore, if
you can actually
do everything in a
single layer instead,
please try to do that instead.
And always be aware that
your window size might
change at any point in time.
And of course, since a
user is, for example,
minimizing you, you might
actually lose your state,
and/or if the window
gets being resized,
the state might
actually be lost.
So please, save your state.
Best practices--
as I said earlier,
we are trying to
work with Play Store
to actually surface
applications which
are really good for the
Chrome OS environment.
So therefore, if you are doing
everything which we asked for,
you will actually
get a better rating.
So therefore, target
SDK bigger than 26.
That is definitely
something good.
Implement keyboard
and mouse navigation.
That is a good thing.
UI elements-- when
you're resizing,
they should always
be inside the screen.
Because if you're alt-tabbing
through something,
and suddenly, your
element is outside
of a screen, that's bad.
When you're doing
resizing, definitely
try to think about
landscape and portrait.
Both orientations
are very important.
Make good use of a lot
of space, because you
have a lot of space.
So use it.
I showed you how to.
Use architectural components
whenever possible in order
to save your state,
or savedInstanceState
does also do the same thing.
Be fluid, and
please, don't crash.
That is really the worst
thing which can happen.
Check out that you
are not crashing.
And with that, I'm
passing it on to Emilie,
who is talking about all the
great tools we have for you.
[APPLAUSE]
EMILIE ROBERTS: Thank you.
There are so many exciting new
things for Android applications
on Chrome OS.
And I'm honored to be able
to present to you three
new amazing developer
tools to help
optimizing your application for
Chrome OS faster and easier.
The first one, you've
all been very patient.
So thank you for your patience.
And a big thank you to
the engineering team
for making this happen
and doing it right.
In Android Studio, we're
pleased to present the Chrome OS
Emulator.
[APPLAUSE]
So right in Android Studio, you
have a full Chrome OS image.
You can test out the
user flow for Chrome OS,
and of course, test and
optimize your app for Android--
your Android application right
in Chrome OS, which is awesome.
However, if any of you have ever
made an Android application--
that's my joke.
OK, some of you did.
Some of you made one.
If you do, you'll
know there's nothing
like testing on a real device,
especially a form factor
like this, where the
user will be flipping it,
rotating it, tossing it on
the bed, keyboard input, mouse
input, MIDI controllers,
stylus input.
You need to test this
on a real device.
So we've made that a lot easier.
I'm very happy to present
ADB debugging over USB.
[APPLAUSE]
It's available for your
Pixelbook and your HP
Chromebook X2.
The public documentation
will be out in a week or two.
So please watch those links--
and more devices coming
soon, and it makes
development that much easier.
OK, so I said there was
three exciting developer
tools we're announcing.
And the first two are awesome.
But I actually think the third
one is even more exciting.
And I truly, truly believe it's
going to knock your socks off.
And we didn't want anyone
to go home with cold feet.
So we brought some
replacement socks
for when they fly off your feet.
Here are some.
And if you're in the middle
the audience or at the back,
don't be jealous.
There's plenty of
socks for everyone.
And on your way out of the
session, you can pick them up.
We're going to people
handing them out.
So that-- yeah, socks, right?
Socks is your new
developer tool.
So I'm going to switch
over to the Chromebook
for a quick demo.
We have a terminal!
Yes, a terminal!
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, terminal, yeah!
Super exciting terminal.
You can see git clone, all
sorts of exciting things.
I cloned the code lab optimizing
your Android application
for Chrome OS, which you
should check out at Codelab 10.
There's dinosaurs.
But what's interesting about
this particular terminal
is it's running inside a
full Linux environment.
No clap?
OK.
You watched the keynote.
OK, fine.
So if you have a full
Linux environment--
you can clap for this next one--
you could install an
application, Linux application,
like Android Studio.
So here we have Android Studio.
[APPLAUSE]
More exciting than
a terminal, I guess.
So here, I have the
Codelab loaded up.
I'm making those
dinosaurs click.
I'm adding drag and drop.
And I go and hit Run.
Oh, so if you're in the
back, and you can't see,
that says Google
Pixelbook, which means,
when I press OK, it goes
through the great old build,
pushing the application
to the device--
what?
On device.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
So look, you can click.
Oh, we got keyboard commands.
And it's pushed it
straight to the device.
So we can program on the
Pixelbook, in Android Studio,
push directly to the
device, test your app out.
And of course, you have
your logcat there with--
and all your debugging tools.
So this is amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah!
And I'm so glad the
engineering team
let me present this
super-exciting announcement.
So we're super excited
about Linux on Chromebooks.
We're going to tell you how
to set it up for yourself.
Before I do, we had a lot
of questions at office hours
and in the Codelab--
what's going on
behind the scenes?
How does this work?
How's it set up?
So I'm going to give
you a brief overview.
Here's Chrome OS.
In real life, it's
a bit snazzier,
but it's a representative box.
And inside there, we have
the Android container.
This is nothing new.
This is now your Android
apps run on Chrome OS today.
Of course, what is new
is we have Linux VM.
And we install
great applications,
like Tux Racer, which they
wouldn't let me show today,
also Android Studio.
And to achieve that last step,
which I think is the most
exciting-- pushing straight
to the app and debugging
on device--
we need to connect ADB
to the Android container.
To do that it's quite simple.
It's the adb connect command.
It's not a secret IP address.
It's the IP address for the
ADBD on the Android container.
This will be in the public-- it
is in the public instructions
already.
But here's a pro tip, since
you came to our session.
For some situations, it's handy
to set up a little SSH tunnel--
simple SSH tunnel
in Chrome OS that
will just forward those
connections automatically-- not
necessary.
It's helpful in some situations.
Here's the instructions
if you haven't--
oops.
Here are the instructions
if you haven't seen it.
I think we were number
one on Hacker News
yesterday or something.
So that's kind of exciting.
Please install it on
your Google Pixelbook,
coming to more devices soon.
We're super excited about it.
Let us know how it works.
Try it out.
So where are we at?
We have an emulator.
We have ADB debugging over USB.
We've got Linux on
Chromebooks running
Android Studio, which
you can debug and develop
on the device.
And you have socks for those
long, cold coding nights,
so your tootsies stay toasty.
What's missing?
Nothing, right?
Except I heard a rumor on
the way in that some of you
don't yet have a Pixelbook.
What?
So we're going to help you
out a little bit with that.
On your way out, when you grab
your socks, you can pick up--
[APPLAUSE]
--a coupon for 75% off
a Google Pixelbook.
Don't forget your socks.
Oh, they're kicking
me off the stage.
So I'm going to say quickly,
come to our Codelabs.
We have two great Codelabs.
You can do the resizing
with animations.
It looks great.
You can make keyboard
input, drag and drop,
click on the dinosaurs, talk
to us at our office hours
today day.
Fill out the survey.
Thank you.
Can everyone back
on stage to bow?
We're done, yes?
Shahid, Frederico, come
on up, Stefan, Paolo.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]